good afternoon I'm Michael Kelleher
program director of the donald windham
sandy m campbell literature prizes on
behalf of the by nikki Rare Book and
Manuscript library I'd like to welcome
all of you to the inaugural Wyndham
Campbell Prize ceremony today's event is
also the kickoff for the first ever
Wyndham Campbell prizes Festival for the
next few days we'll celebrate the work
of our Prize winners with a series of
readings talks classes book signings we
hope to make this an annual event to
start the school year and we look
forward to seeing you throughout the
week before we begin I'd like to take a
minute to thank everyone involved in
making the prizes and festival a reality
the estate of donald windham the office
of the university president the office
of development the director and staff of
the by Nicki library the prize steering
committee the nominators jurors and
members of the selection committee the
Whitney humanities center Yale School of
Drama Yale theater studies program the
Masters of brantford Calhoun Ezra Stiles
Jonathan Edwards Moore's Pearson and
Saybrook colleges the Department of
English the department of African
American Studies Yale Council on African
Studies Council on Middle Eastern
Studies afro-american cultural center
Jackson Institute for Global Affairs
Yale School of Music Yale University art
gallery Yale Law School office of the
University printer Yale University
Bookstore cooperative arts and
humanities high school and special
thanks to my assistant Jennifer
Castellon who has silently made this
whole thing happen
when people ask about the Windham
Campbell prizes they usually have three
questions where does the money come from
how did the prizes end up at Yale and
how are the prize winners selected
usually in that order to answer the
first two questions I need to tell you a
little bit about Donald Windham and
Sandi Campbell Windham was a writer
Campbell an actor
Windham wrote novels short stories
memoirs plays even a children's book
Campbell acted on Broadway and in
traveling companies they counted among
their friends some of the most important
artists of their time Tennessee Williams
Truman Capote Joseph Cornell and
Montgomery Clift the list goes on the
two remained a couple from the time they
met in the early 40s until sandy
Campbell's untimely death in 1988 as a
young man Wyndham co-wrote a play with
Tennessee Williams called
you touched me based on a story by D H
Lawrence while it was not a huge
box-office success the royalties he
received allowed him to quit his job and
devote himself to his first novel
financial freedom provided the time he
needed to focus on his writing Wyndham
and Campbell had discussed the idea of
creating an award to support writers for
many years
inspired by Windham inspired by the
important role financial independence
had played in Wyndham career as a writer
when Campbell passed away Wyndham took
on the responsibility for making this
shared dream a reality out of devotion
to Campbell's memory Wyndham ignored the
advice of his financial advisers and
retained the Campbell family stocks he'd
inherited his resolve and modest
lifestyle were rewarded and he became
wealthy enough to realize their goal of
creating a global Literature Prize
Wyndham had already entrusted some of
his papers to the by Nicky Rare Book and
Manuscript library and the relationship
he developed with the by Nickie
convinced him that Yale was the ideal
place to create a prize of the scale and
prestige they
envisioned to answer the third question
in detail I refer you to our website
ww-when dem Campbell org which contains
a detailed explanation of the selection
process in brief the nominators literary
denominators who are all literary
experts from around the world nominated
20 writers in drama fiction and
nonfiction a three-person jury in each
category selected 5 finalists from among
the 20 an 8 member selection committee
made the final decisions in all three
categories
tonight we honor the 9 writers whose
work inspired the nominators to nominate
them the jurors to move them forward in
the process and the selection committee
to single out their extraordinary work
for recognition Stephen Adly Jurgis
Adina Hoffman Tarell Alvin McCraney Tom
McCarthy James Salter Jeremy Scahill
Gianni Steinberg
Naomi Wallace and Zoe Wickham to present
them with their awards please welcome
Peter Salome
thank you very much Michael welcome good
afternoon everyone
my name is Peter Salome the fairly new
president of Yale University this is I
think day 72 for me but it is certainly
one of the most exciting ones so far and
I'm just delighted to be a part of this
inaugural celebration I want to thank in
addition to Michael you showed ER and
the Beinecke Rare Book and Manuscript
library as they are the custodian of
this extraordinary prize and you know
inauguration is as you might guess as a
topical subject for me at the moment
and so let me say I'm really just doubly
excited that we inaugurate this very
week the donald windham sandy campbell
literature prizes and The Associated
Festival as Michael noted in his remarks
it was the relationship that he
developed with yell that led donald
windham to establish the prizes here I
don't know exactly what Wyndham was
thinking when he made his decision but I
have thought a bit about the qualities
Yale possesses that make it the ideal
place to establish prizes of such
distinction
Yale is a place that hopes to recognize
inspire and nurture excellence in every
field the group of writers we honor here
today embodies the ideal in this ideal
in the field of world literature it is
our hope that these prizes will help
them continue to pursue excellence in
their writing so that we might benefit
from the work they produce but Yale is
not just about winning prizes I think
perhaps the key word in Michaels
description is relationship when people
like Donald Windham give their papers to
the Beinecke e-library
they enter into a relationship with the
students and professors at Yale and with
the worldwide community of scholars
artists and thinkers who form the
bedrock upon which the university is
built it's my feeling that by
establishing the prizes here at Yale
Donna McDonald Wyndham knew that he was
placing them in the care of a friend who
shared his concerns that writers be
supported and that their achievements
not go unrecognized today we recognize
those achievements as we welcome our
Prize winners into our community to all
of them I would like to say
congratulations and welcome to you
now we will bestow the prizes the donald
windham sandy campbell literature prizes
call attention to literary achievement
and provide writers with the opportunity
to focus on their work independent of
financial concerns at least for a while
prizes are awarded annually in the
categories of drama nonfiction and
fiction english-language writers from
anywhere in the world and at any stage
of their careers are eligible for
consideration and each Prize winner
receives a citation and one hundred and
fifty thousand dollars to support their
writing today each of our honorees will
receive a prize diploma the diplomas are
hand bound artist books designed by
Sarah Horowitz of Portland Oregon
each diploma features the prize citation
and an original pen-and-ink drawing by
the artist so let's start with the drama
category the three Prize winners are
Stephen Adly Girgis Terrell Alvin
McCraney
and Naomi Wallace Stephen Adly kyrgyz is
a playwright whose work brings
underrepresented voices the poor the
imprisoned the traitorous the betrayed
too vivid writers life gigas is a
longtime member and former artistic
director of New York City's labyrinth
Theatre Company a groundbreaking
ensemble of actors committed to writing
and staging their own productions a
number of Geragos plays were first
produced by labyrinth under the
direction of Philip Seymour Hoffman
including the little flower of East
Orange I grew up very near East Orange
so this
when rings true for me the last days of
judas iscariot and in arabia we'd all be
kings
his most recent play the [ __ ]
with the hat about an ex-convict and a
drug addict described in the new yorker
as one of the most beautifully drawn
couples to appear on the stage in years
premiered on Broadway in 2011 and
received six Tony nominations now my
guess is that isn't the first time that
word has been uttered from this stage
but it certainly was the first time I
muttered by Yale President John I hope
that was for the playwright a former
violence prevention specialist and HIV
educator jurgis has facilitated numerous
workshops in the New York City area in
prisons in schools in shelters and in
hospitals the prize citation for Stephen
Adly Girgis reads Stephen Adly Girgis
writes dramatic dialogue with passion
and humor creating characters who live
on the edge and whose linguistic bravado
reinvigorates the American vernacular
Steve
tell Alvin McCraney is a playwright and
actor best known for his acclaimed
trilogy the brother-sister plays which
blends myth with realism in the
intergenerational story of an
african-american community in Louisiana
mcrainey has been lauded as the kind of
voice that can define a generation Ben
Bradley wrote of the brother-sister
plays in the New York Times it is what
people must have felt during productions
of the early works of Eugene O'Neill in
the 1920s or of Sam Shepard in the 1960s
McCraney is an ensemble member of
Chicago Steppenwolf theatre company
which premiered his new play head of
passes this spring he is also a resident
playwright at new dramatists and a
member of teo casting a Castaignos
d projects in miami where he grew up in
the libris liberty city housing projects
in the 1980s but crannies other plays
include the breach written with Joe
Sutton and Catherine fellow about
Hurricane Katrina and wig-out about a
family of New York drag queens his
latest play choirboy was produced at the
Manhattan Theatre Club he is a graduate
of the Yale School of Drama the prize
citation for Terrell Alvin McCraney
reads tell Evan McQueen e's
working-class characters inhabit an
extraordinary mythic universe speaking
of poetic language through which we
grasp the spiritual stature of embattled
people congratulations to
Naomi Wallace is an American playwright
living in England
throughout her celebrated and incendiary
career Wallace has explored the role of
politics and power in shaping human
experience be it 17th century London
during the Great Plague in one flee
spare among black communists organizers
in 1930s Alabama things of dry hours or
in the parallel drama's of the Vietnam
and Gulf Wars in the heart of America
though her work can be dark and almost
brutal in its vision Tony Kushner
maintains that Wallace is outrageously
optimistic she seems to believe that the
world can change
she certainly writes as she intends to
set it on fire
her most recent play the liquid plane
won the 2012 horton Foote prize for the
most promising new American play and had
its world premiere at the Oregon
Shakespeare Festival in July the prize
citation for now me Wallace reads now
Lee Wallace mines historical situations
in plays that are muscular devastating
and unwavering no
congratulations in the gesture
so I have to just say something personal
many of you know I'm a psychologist but
I have a brother who's an associate
artistic director of a theatre the San
Diego rep theatre and I sent him a
little note about our three playwrights
who won last night and he wrote me back
this a few civ note saying he just
couldn't believe who we were honoring
and he wished he could fly in and he
went on and on like this I I was just
really thrilled that I could impress my
brother through the three of you he's
hard to impress okay the three Prize
winners in the nonfiction category are
Adina Hoffman Jeremy Scahill
and Johnny Steinberg Adina Hoffman is
the author of three non-fiction books
that expand and enrich our understanding
of the Middle East through their
juxtaposition of personal and political
histories in my happiness there's no
relation to happiness a poet's life in
the Palestinians century Hoffman
Hoffman's meticulously researched and
vividly written biography of the
Palestinian poet Taha Muhammad Ali
becomes a window onto the fate of the
Palestinian people in the wake of the
1948 war and its ensuing displacements
Hoffman divides her time between New
Haven and Jerusalem and house of windows
portraits from a Jerusalem neighborhood
provides an intimate portrait of daily
life in the conflict-ridden
city sacred trash the lost-and-found
world of the Cairo Genizah
written with Peter Cole tells the story
of both the discovery of an astonishing
trove of Jewish manuscripts in Egypt and
the remarkable men and women who brought
it to light the prize citation for Adina
Hoffman reads in a land where even the
most
cautious nonfiction can draw howls of
protest Edina Hoffman combines
fastidious listening even-handed
research and prose so engaging that it
makes the long-vanished visible again
Edina
Jeremy Scahill is an investigative
journalist and author whose work has
sparked several congressional
investigations and one summon of some of
journalism's highest honors his
reporting has led him to Afghanistan
Iraq Somalia Yemen the former Yugoslavia
and elsewhere across the globe in
addition to his work as national
security correspondent for the nation
and puffin writing fellow at the nation
Institute scale is the author of the
best-selling books Blackwater the rise
of the world's most powerful mercenary
army and dirty wars the world is a
battlefield battlefield he also wrote
and produced the documentary film dirty
wars which exposes covert American
counterterrorism operations including
targeted killings and drone strikes
executed without congressional oversight
or public debate scale was twice awarded
the George Polk award for his work the
prize citation for Jeremy Scahill
reads Jeremy Scahill investigative
reporting is in the best tradition of
speaking truth to power waging a
political campaign by journalistic means
indefatigable in its detail in
international in Outlook German
but diversity is good
Jonnie Steinberg is a South African
writer and scholar in books like
Midlands about the murder of a white
South African farmer and the number a
biography of a prison gang member
Steinberg uses personal narratives to
shed new light on contemporary South
African life and politics 3-letter
plague tells the story of one South
African man's refusal to be tested for
HIV hallucinating the deep stigma and
cultural ambivalence that continue to
characterize the country's hiv/aids
epidemic Steinberg has recently expanded
his attention beyond South Africa with
the publication of little Liberia in
which the trauma of Liberia's civil war
is approached obliquely through an
exiled community and exile community in
New York in addition to his book
Steinberg is a regular columnist for
South Africa's business day and a
lecturer in African Studies at the
University of Oxford the prize citation
for Johnny Steinberg reads using a
novelistic style that gives every day
people heroic complexity and scale
Johnny Steinberg allows us to encounter
lives that enlarge our empathy and
sharpen our understanding of the human
condition Johnny
we now come to the three Prize winners
in the fiction category and they are Tom
McCarthy James Salter and Zoe Wickham
Tom McCarthy is a writer and artist from
London England since the publication of
his first novel remainder in 2005
praised by Zadie Smith in the New York
Review of Books as one of the great
English novels of the last ten years
because these writing has boldly
expanded our conception of what fiction
should look like and what it can do in
remainder an unnamed narrator suffers a
brain injury and uses the settlement
money
to stage elaborate reenactments of his
memories and dreams the novel won the
2008 beliver Book Award and in Smith's
words offered a glimpse of an alternate
road down which the novel might with
difficulty travel forward his two
subsequent novels novels men in space
and see further rupture and revise
conventional understandings of the
individual self in relation to his world
see was a finalist for the 2010 Man
Booker Prize McCarthy is also a founder
and general secretary of the
International necro nautical Society I&S
a semi fictitious network of writers
philosophers and artists intervening
against idealism and philosophy and
idealist or transcendent conceptions of
art the prize citation for Tom McCarthy
reads Tom McCarthy constructs strange
worlds where we find reflective echoes
of our own and meditations on the
meaning and making of art Tom
James Salter is the author of six novels
and two short story collections born in
1925 James Salter grew up in New York
City graduated from West Point and
served in the US Army Air Force for 12
years his first novel the hunters drew
out his experience as a pilot in the
Korean War soon after its publication
saltar resigned from the Air Force in
order to devote himself wholly to his
writing because other novels include a
sport and a pastime a classic of erotic
realism and light years his subject is
human desire in its many forms longing
jealousy ambition the need to triumph to
achieve perfection to be loved to belong
very much
the dream of a psychologist who finds
himself a university president I think
all that is his first novel in 35 years
was published this April
it was welcomed by the New York Times as
a work that manages to both be to be
both recognizable no one but Salter
could have written it and yet strikingly
original vigorous proof that this
literary lion is still very much on the
prowl the prize citation for James
Salter reads sentence by sentence James
Salter's elegantly natural prose has a
precision and clarity which make
ordinary words swing wide open
Zoli Wickham was born in South Africa
and lives in Glasgow Scotland her
fiction demonstrates an ongoing
preoccupation with deep insight into
apartheid and its legacies in prose held
by Toni Morrison as seductive brilliance
and precious wickham's first book of
stories you can't get lost in Cape Town
articulates the experience of mixed-race
or colored South Africans under
apartheid in her two subsequent novels
David's story and playing in the light
and her most recent story collection the
one that got away
welcome why does her focus to explore
the persistent influence of race and
gender in shaping South African life in
a post apartheid society and an
increasingly interconnected world
Wycombe is an emeritus professor at the
University of Strathclyde the prize
citation for Zoe with them reads Zoe
Wickham's subtle lively language and
beautifully crafted narratives explore
the complex entanglements of home and
the continuing challenges of being in
the world
so please join me one last time as I
asked our prize winners to rise and
imitate their photographs here and
accept our applause the first funnel
Wyndham sandy Campbell
literature Club